I'm here with our brother Ben Ben for
those coming up who lack motivation
seeking motivation you're a world
champion what advice you give to get
peep the kids motivated to get them into
the sport stay into this point yeah I
saw I think I think a really important
point is that the kids had they have to
have an understanding this gonna be a
long tough journey and a lot of people
like to say kids these days don't they
don't want that difficulty they don't
want that university but I see it as the
opposite I brought I coach the kids club
and I see once kids get into it they
love the journey they love the battle
and so teaching them to enjoy the sport
so that when things get tough when
things get hard which they never
invariably will always get hard that
they're ready to stick through it and
develop a toughness and that something
to help them in the sport that's gonna
help them all the way through the life
because as we know life isn't always
easy sometimes a kick in the butt Thank
You Ben